[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de Paf
nous allons balayer une actualité
chargée qui va du drame qui s'est
déroule à Coignières un jeune enfant de
14 ans a trouvé la mort au débat sur la
tauromachie en passant par l'inscription
de l'IVG peut-être dans la Constitution
donc nous avons beaucoup de choses à
dire et pour les dire Véronique Jérôme
bonjour Patrice vous êtes maître de
conférence de
d'économie de gestion à Paris Saclay
ATIS barré bonjour bonjour Patrice
vous êtes conseiller municipal à Poissy
délégué à la biodiversité et au
bien-être animal tout à fait
Florence Mercadet bonjour Patrice
et Jean-Charles lajani vous êtes éditeur
et cette idée vous étiez au
alors justement et bien justement nous
sommes nous sommes aussi avec
Jean-Michel je le sers merci d'être avec
nous
vous êtes vous êtes blog vous êtes vous
êtes docteur en sociologie et vous êtes
notamment chercheurs au centre de
recherche sur les institutions de
l'Université de Versailles sont communs
vous êtes aussi chercheurs à
l'Université de Reims et je vous montre
voilà le livre que de que vous êtes
publié Jean-Charles qui va vous
intéresser parce que ça s'appelle 22 vla
les flics c'est des nouvelles
écrite par des anciens flics
soit des flics sur des expliques qui
nous ont confié une nouvelle inédite
plus ou moins sur le thème de l'enfance
avec des enfants victimes ou des enfants
parfois criminels d'ailleurs dans le
dans ce livre et tous les droits
d'auteurs vont voilà des droits d'auteur
plus une part de de
l'argent qu'on est censé toucher on
reverse un euro 50 aux orphelins de la
police d'accord voilà et alors je lui
dis ça Jean-Michel parce que Jean-Michel
avant d'être chercheur était policier
c'est ça
phénomène qui existe depuis déjà que
plusieurs années qui est récurrent mais
exponentielle depuis quelques temps il
est il est clair que il va falloir
cesser le débat sur la société telle
violente devient-elle violente telle de
plus en plus violente elle est
effectivement moi je note surtout une
chose dans ce cette augmentation des
violences et qu'on voit parallèlement de
façon quasi systématique maintenant
avec et au-delà de ces violences
l'utilisation de d'armes soit d'arme
blanche soit ce qu'on appelle l'endroit
d'armes par destination il traduisent
pour moi une véritable volonté de faire
mal alors au sens très fort du terme
voire plus loin de tuer ça c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement extrêmement
préoccupant et je crois que en même
temps face à des esprits qui n'ont pas
encore le recul nécessaire pour avoir
précisément ce qu'on appelle un esprit
critique il y a aussi vous utilisez le
sociétale tout à l'heure il y a aussi
quelque chose qui pour moi me semble
très important
au-delà des mesures de prévention des
mesures de répression ce fameux couple
dont on discute depuis des années il y a
une ambiance très violente dans la
société elle-même prend deux exemples
très simples vous savez vous allez me
dire ce ne sont des mots mais les mots
leur importance donc dans tous les
domaines j'ai observe ces derniers temps
que soit dans le domaine journalistique
sportif culturel
l'emploi de termes qui confine qui sont
qui sont en fait un vocabulaire guerrier
regardez en sport par exemple deux
équipes se rencontrent il y a quelques
années
une équipe à les battre l'autre
aujourd'hui on va les défoncer vous avez
y compris dans le domaine culturel des
concours de chant ce sont plus des
concours ce sont des batailles en
anglais plus et on va on va s'affronter
comme si on pouvait s'affronter en
chantant alors ça peut être sur le
moment pas une grande importance sauf
que ça infuse dans des esprits qui ne
sont pas encore totalement développés
totalement formé à l'esprit critique et
c'est quelque chose qui à mon avis
renforce aussi cette violence à côté de
ça il y a les constats habituels qu'on a
fait
sauf que il serait temps que les
pouvoirs publics alors tant nationaux
que locaux
s'entendent pour enfin apporter des
réponses et cesser de faire toujours les
mêmes const sur quant à ce encore une
fois ce débattre sur y a-t-il ou pas
violence oui il y a violence clairement
et même les sociologues qui pendant
enfin certains sociologues qui pendant
des années avaient tendance à mettre
uniquement sur le social la cause de
tous ces mots moi je dirais aujourd'hui
que social ou sociétal est un mot m od
qui cache parfois le manque d'ambition
et le manque de résultats qu'on a face
au mot Emmaüs
j'aurais souhaité vous poser une
question monsieur est-ce qu'on peut voir
ce développement de
de violence physique depuis
les réseaux sociaux ou ça peut se
déchaîner sur les réseaux sociaux de
façon
verbale mais
qui des fois aussi au travers de
harcèlement extrêmement violent peuvent
aussi se traduire par derrière des
violences physiques donc est-ce qu'on
peut observer cette augmentation de
violence réelle physique par le
développement des réseaux sociaux
oui vous avez tout à fait raison il y a
un lien les réseaux sociaux sont devenus
à un incubateur voire un accélérateur de
cette violence il y a des on se teste
par les réseaux sociaux on s'agresse par
les réseaux sociaux alors là en
l'occurrence bien sûr verbalement je
trouve que c'est toujours là encore une
fois
c'est très connoté l'utilisation des
mots je l'ai encore à son importance et
effectivement c'est une caisse de
résonance d'amplification de provocation
et voit d'ailleurs alors il y a le
l'exemple le plus frappant c'est les
groupes d'Europe alors est-ce que c'est
une posture est-ce qu'ils en jouent ou
pas mais en tout cas le résultat on le
connaît oui les réseaux sociaux
incontestablement ce ne sont pas les
seuls responsables malheureusement mais
les réseaux sociaux jouent un rôle
effectivement très important dans cette
pensée de la violence
vous parlez de cette violence qui
s'infusent dans toute la société et
c'est des très jeunes puisque là la
victime à 14 ans est-ce que justement le
fait que ça soit des des tout jeunes
gens des tout jeunes ados on n'a pas des
ados c'est presque des enfants complique
le travail peut-être de la police ou de
travail de prévention et de répression
d'ailleurs
compliqué à deux niveaux le travail de
la police et le travail de la justice
d'abord parce que ce sont des mineurs et
que on est en France
relance nos lances toujours dans l'idée
de chien perdu son collier or Gilbert
Cesbron c'était il y a très très
longtemps aujourd'hui la violence n'est
plus la même mais il y a toujours si
vous voulez cette législation sur les
mineurs qui vont procédure allemand
compliquer mais surtout ce qui complique
en plus à mon sens et ça tous les
policiers actuellement services vous le
diront il y a une non prise en compte de
ces événements violents et les jeunes
bien souvent n'ont
y compris quand ils sont devant les
policiers ou devant les juges donc
aucune conscience réelle de ce qu'ils
ont fait bon je l'ai fait voilà ça n'a
pas une grande importance et pour en
revenir à la question de votre de Madame
il y a deux minutes à propos des réseaux
sociaux là aussi on peut faire un lien à
savoir que j'ai donné un coup de couteau
vous savez sur un réseau social ou sur
un jeu sur si au jeu
que l'adversaire tombe on appuie sur la
touche RESET et puis tout va bien sauf
que dans la vie il n'y a pas de recette
mais chez les jeunes on n'a pas une
grande importance et ont-ils
véritablement conscience de leur acte et
de la profondeur de l'oracle et de leur
responsabilités très souvent les
policiers des magistrats vous diront que
c'est terrible mais malheureusement la
plupart des cas non
certaine
impunité pour les belligérants vu leur
âge parce que c'est vrai que
c'est ça aussi c'est que comme je pars
sous le contrôle de maître Mercadet mais
si on a moins de 13 ans il y a quasiment
pas de sanctions pénale possible si
non moins de 13 ans non mais là en
l'espèce la personne qui a attaqué ce
jeune à 16 ans
très jeunes quand on a des situations
aussi dramatiques il se trouve que le
jeune
en question va peut-être se retrouver
avec famille d'accueil où il va être
sorti de sa famille où il va y avoir
quand même un suivi par un juge pour
enfants va y avoir quand même des choses
qui vont se qui vont se déclencher qui
sont effectivement c'est pas de la
prison mais il y a derrière tout un
suivi qui se met en place au moins
jusqu'à sa majorité ce qui est aussi une
certaine contrainte mais bon ça peut ne
pas être ça peut ne pas être entendu
aussi par par la société parce que ce
sera pas ce seront pas des peines
d'emprisonnement et des peines radicales
il y a des choses qui marchent alors
c'est très compliqué de dire comment
éviter ce genre de meurtre mais il y a
des choses qui va il y a la sociative
quand même parfois dans dans les
quartiers et il y a la dérivation de la
violence et je sais que dans des
banlieues où il y avait des comme ça des
bandes rivales et ils les ont fait
entraîner par des par des des stars de
la MMA par exemple et du coup ils ont
dérivé les le conflit une sorte de jeu
et ça plutôt marché
justement la sortie d'un truc de MMA oui
là il se trouve que là
sauf que là ils avaient entraîné des
bonnes rivales et chacun avait et donc
ils sont combattus mais ça a été un
combat presque en règle avec des règles
quoi
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est des
solutions qui peuvent fonctionner c'est
une solution mais bon
peut-être dangereux surtout s'agissant
de MMA mais souvenons-nous que pendant
des années le sport constituait un moyen
un moyen d'échange un moyen de pratique
de l'altérité de la connaissance et de
la reconnaissance et du respect bien
évidemment de l'autre en fonction de
certaines règles je lisais pas plus tard
que ce matin l'interview d'un maire ou
d'une commune de la banlieue parisienne
je sais plus laquelle et qui disait
qu'il a mis il a mis en place quelque
chose qui me semble intéressant c'est de
prendre des gamins entre 11 12 et 16 ans
de différents quartiers voire de
différentes communes et de les faire
vivre ensemble c'est le cas de le dire
de les habituer vous savez parce qu'il y
a aussi cette confrontation de
territoire de les habituer à se
connaître
connaître l'autre c'est un grand pas de
de fait ça je pense que ça peut être une
bonne chose et je dirais dans le même
temps il y a aussi le fait de sortir
certains jeunes d'un engrenage qui
fonctionne beaucoup par ce que j'appelle
moi le mimétisme métier avec des rites
de passage des rides de passage violents
notamment tu vas agresser ceci tu vas
voler cela tu vas voir on a vu même dans
certains gangs
à l'image des gangs américains au départ
ça commence à venir en France on en est
pas encore là mais on fait un bon
j'espère que ça ne viendra pas mais je
suis assez peu optimiste pour tout vous
dire des systèmes de passage à l'acte et
tant qu'on est si vous voulez pris dans
ce dans ce mécanisme qui devient vite un
Mael Strom de violence donc il faut
sortir il faut sortir les gamins de ce
milieu-là alors les sorties ça veut pas
dire forcément les mettre en prison mais
en tout cas il y a la nécessité de les
évacuer d'un monde constant de violence
encore une fois de violence physique de
violences verbale de violence
morale il y a quelque chose à faire et
puis bien évidemment combattre le
sentiment d'insécu de d'impunité pardon
qui est je peux vous le dire très très
fort chez ces jeunes qui s'estiment que
rien ne peut m'arriver d'abord parce que
comme l'a dit l'avocate je suis mineur
donc voilà et puis quand je serai
je serai un mineur un peu plus vieux
c'est à dire accessible à une sanction
pénale mais malgré tout avec des
possibilités de
d'une peine peut-être un peu moins
lourde
alors vous savez quand vous avez un
dossier avec 20 ou 30 ou 40 inscriptions
et que vous arrivez à 18 ans qu'on vous
donne une première vraie peine vous ne
la comprenez pas quelque part je dirais
que c'est assez c'est assez normal et
c'est assez humain c'est dangereux
une dernière question de l'avocate
au delà de la problématique des réseaux
sociaux il y a les jeux vidéo aussi qui
sont
pas excusez-moi oui parce qu'il y a des
jeux vidéos
hyper violent avec des jeunes qui
restent quatre heures cinq heures et en
plus en réseau à ce combattre au travers
de jeux vidéo hyper violent et ça il y a
peut-être une responsabilité des parents
qui laisse faire parce que pendant ce
temps-là ils font autre chose s'il y a
des parents exactement et en plus ils
font ça la nuit
or probablement on l'a vu des parents
donc ça c'est jeux vidéo hyper violent
sont aussi
dérivatif ou si c'est excitant aussi
sympathique c'est-à-dire que il se dit
Monsieur il se rendent plus compte de ce
qu'ils font parce que dans le jeu vidéo
ils le font et dans la et ils ont
peut-être un problème de de d'absence de
dissociation entre le jeu vidéo et la
vraie vie mais c'est vrai Jean-Michel
chausseur des crédits pas trop si c'est
cathartique comme dit Jean-Charles ou si
ça conduit plus de violence on se débat
toujours de ça non
[Musique]
de famille je pense que là il faut
encore les vraies victimes sont les
familles et la douleur est irréparable
je pense que la société ne pas de
réponse sur ces fonds
[Musique]
d'être avec vous merci beaucoup merci
alors on va on va passer à d'autres
actualités alors il y en a une première
comme ça il y a plusieurs petites choses
je vous demandais si ça vous intéresse
ou pas on va faire l'actualité en vrac
[Musique]
alors
première actualiser oui c'est vous avez
vu qui est il va y avoir une française
dans les dans les étoiles
qui s'appelle le Sophie Adnot qui est
ingénieur qui est pilote pilote de décès
d'hélicoptère ça va être pas mal ça
c'est intéressant qu'on revienne quand
même à cette conquête de l'espace si en
même temps qu'on va dans l'espace on
pouvait essayer de parler français tout
le monde parle d'astronautes en fait en
Europe ce sont des spationautes voilà
donc si on pouvait de temps en temps
employer les bons termes ce serait
les taïkonautes sont chinois et il y a
un truc pour les indiens dont je me
souviens plus un autre qui était assez
comique mais voilà mais donc
mais c'est bien non c'est vrai que la
conquête de l'espace et c'est quelque
chose qu'on semblait avoir abandonné
alors elle revient aujourd'hui notamment
il y a le l'Atmos de l'UVSQ qui envoie
beaucoup de de
satellite microsatellite et c'est vrai
il paraît que l'espace et c'est un
embouteillage
non c'est vrai
on peut comme une copropriété ce qui est
à tout le monde est à personne
c'est-à-dire qu'on aime en profiter mais
pour gérer et pour enfin instituer des
règles et justement cette pollution
qu'on peut avoir qui va qui va décider
c'est un c'est un sujet
assez vaste et c'est vrai que oui
il y a un droit maritime je sais pas
s'il y a un droit de l'espace qui qui
attribue des
droits de propriété justement mais le
problème
était infini parce que c'est impossible
de déterminer dès qu'on parle de
l'espace on s'envole
et après qu'on envisage vraiment d'aller
sur Mars c'est c'est plus soufflant ça
ça donne vraiment quand même
ce qui se prépare pour aller sur Mars
peut-être un jour je sais pas comment on
va faire parce que c'est combien de
temps pour
aimer le voyage
c'est un an et demi de voyage je pense
qu'on a pas envie de rester 2 minutes
donc c'est une vraie question les
retombées économiques parce que
finalement il y a des vrais barrières à
l'entrée il y a presque même des suncos
des couilles récupérables parce qu'une
fois qu'on a investi on n'est pas sûr
d'avoir la possibilité de tout utiliser
et donc cette question des des retombées
je crois que c'est Bronson qui disait
alors c'est pas le temps c'est pas
l'espace mais c'est l'aéronautique c'est
un peu paraît pareil pour être
millionnaire dans l'aéronautique faut
commencer milliardaires et il y a
vraiment cet aspect on a l'impression
que ça fouille
et on peut pas s'en priver absolument
magnifique notamment sur le corps humain
et peut-être il y avait aussi l'idée
aussi d'avoir d'autres planètes
possibles pour la vie
une planète poubelle par exemple tous
nos déchets
voilà alors donc ça c'est de l'espace
deuxième petite info en politique
monsieur catenas alors
député des filles vous savez que donc
accusé d'avoir frappé son épouse qui
sont divorce etc est-ce qu'ils peuvent
vivre l'assemblée ça semble un peu
compliqué dans son propre groupe mais
oui mais là on est au Bon Temps du
stalinisme enfin je veux dire le type
est non mais il est accusé ok il est
accusé je sais pas la présomption
d'innocence c'est comme important il a
pas été jugé par qui que ce soit si ce
n'est pas un comité un comité politique
de la nups
c'est une reconnaissance de culpabilité
ce qui n'est pas la même chose parce que
ça veut dire oui non mais ça veut dire
qu'il faut que lui accepte connaître sa
culpabilité et négocie la peine avec le
parquet et ensuite que ce soit homologué
par un juge donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'il reconnaisse sa culpabilité et je
suis pas sûr qu'on soit parti là-dessus
pour l'instant après on regarde par le
trou de la serrure et moi je trouve ça
un peu quand même voilà déplacé après ce
qui est compliqué c'est que il est alors
si j'ai bien compris il est temps de
l'arrêt maladie mais il peut continuer à
voter et là il y a un vrai il y a une
vraie question politique parce que lui
demander de partir ça signifierait
finalement il ne peut plus voter donc il
y a peut-être aussi un enjeu politique
qui fait que il n'est ni soutenu ni
enfoncé par par son parti on peut faire
un parallèle avec les élus représentants
du personnel ils sont en arrêt maladie
mais ils peuvent ils peuvent venir
exercer leur mandat et voter
c'est un peu ça et puis les classiques
et plutôt les femmes et les hommes
d'ailleurs
c'est que encore une fois moi c'est pas
du tout mes opinions politiques monsieur
katnas mais il y a cette présence et
ensuite les gens ne sont partis ou de
l'autre partie de chez les écolos
ayatollah qui disent qu'il doit s'en
aller mais je veux dire il a pas volé
son élection il a été élu par le peuple
d'ailleurs qui se représente un autre
élection et qui ne soit plus élue certes
très bien mais
démissionnent qui se représentent et
s'il avait la légitimité d'une autre
élection ça serait beaucoup plus
difficile de
lui demander de démissionner de se faire
réélire alors que il est pour le moment
présumé innocent
le reproche maintenant c'est beaucoup
plus grave
politique soit exemplaire on a attendu
une exemplarité le sujet de la violence
faite aux femmes est un sujet qui a été
vraiment pris et mis en avant par ce
gouvernement en particulier enfin par
les autres aussi d'ailleurs mais à
partir du moment où on veut mettre ce
sujet en avant il faut qu'on soit en
cohérence avec ses faits ces paroles et
ses actes je dis pas je veux pas
l'accuser nécessairement mais je trouve
que le message qui est envoyé
mais ce que je trouve assez choquant
c'est que on a pour le moment qu'une
seule version on n'a pas l'acier alors
il dit reconnaît une vie dans quelles
conditions ça s'est passé qu'est-ce que
elle parce que pour arriver à mettre une
gifle c'est je pense que le le l'échange
entre eux n'était pas hyper calme
non
dans sa vie une fois dans cette dans ce
cas là on peut jamais se permettre de
fixer aux enfants
national enfin ne doit pas arriver à
mettre gifle il est censé représenter
les autres hommes aussi dans un couple
on peut s'engueuler on peut se gronder
mais c'est pas pour autant qu'une femme
va recevoir une gifle par un homme parce
que elle a dit un mot de plus il y a une
disproportion par rapport à ça d'abord
un sa femme avait demandé à ce que ça ne
soit pas dit et est-ce que ça reste
confidentiel au début alors après
non mais au démarrage c'est une
politique qui a qui a mis ça sur la
table alors que ça faisait quelque chose
de privé et je ne veux pas que ce soit
dit donc il y a une instrumentalisation
par une personne féministe et moi ça me
choque ça c'est sûr
la symbolique derrière c'est que si lui
ce même être à mettre une gifle bah là
tout à l'heure on parlait dans les
quartiers et bah dans les quartiers on
va dire bah c'est tout à fait normal
qu'on arrive
encore plus loin
elle l'avait giflé donc voilà on verra
attention
on doit
essayer
une claque de l'autre voilà attendons
que les professionnels de professions
fassent leur boulot
il y en a qu'une et je moi ce qui me
choque c'est de pouvoir juger les choses
sur une version mais ça c'est l'avocat
qui parle
parce que sa violence à sa place à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est juste la
question et c'est ce que dit je suis
assez d'accord avec ça un homme coupable
pas non pour l'instant
c'est la justice qui doit trancher c'est
pas un quarteron de féministe surexcité
qui va qui va juger qui va nous dire qui
a le droit de représenter qui a le droit
de représenter le peuple ou pas sur
excité quand il frappe
le dauphin Mélenchon aussi donc il y
avait une carrière pour le premier thème
carrière assez brillante peut-être que
c'est une façon aussi de lui couper les
ailes donc là il y a aussi cet élément
là je pense que c'est parce que la
manipulation
outrageusement monsieur Baillou qui
n'est pas non plus mon idole mais enfin
je veux dire elles avaient quand même
monté un comité qui a enquêté pendant 3
ans sur sa vie privée pour arriver à
prouver que c'était pas bien mais jamais
été entendu j'ai entendre ça j'ai pas
envie d'entendre
est-ce que c'est Sandrine Rousseau qui
est capable de d'organiser un coup
politique aussi immonde que celui-là à
sa place à l'Assemblée
elle se base sur des faits donc j'ai
trois personnes pendant trois ans
témoigner un certain nombre de milliers
pourquoi n'a-t-il pas été entendu lui
pour avoir sa version
LFI mais dans la Commission et les
filles jamais été entendu je suis désolé
mais on est en démocratie il y a des
règles non mais c'est vrai mais qu'on
est dans un monde où la justice n'est
pas le seul maître étalon
dans un certain nombre de cassé
notamment sur les violences faites aux
femmes parce que bah il y a eu beaucoup
qui ne sont pas qui ne sont pas apparus
au jour parce que justement parce qu'il
y avait une chape de plomb et ben ça
change évidemment vous êtes dans une
période où peut-être il y a des
équilibre d'un côté mais
dans un autre équilibre mais quand même
s'il faut attendre que les policiers
veuillent bien prendre les plaintes que
les juges veulent bien juger pour que
pour que ça vienne
je suis pas d'accord avec
dans mon entourage j'ai des femmes qui
sont menacées qui ont du mal à divorcer
elles vont voir les officiers de police
on les prend pas au sérieux vous revenez
vous repassez à telle heure et les
femmes disent on est réellement menacé
réellement menacés
je trouve très choquant il y a une
commission qui est avec des gens qui
sont des députés des parlementaires donc
qui représentent le peuple aussi et qui
n'entendent qu'une version et qui
n'entendent pas monsieur Bayou et qui
partent bi en tête sur les versions de
ces femmes qui sont propres qui sont
peut-être vrai je sais pas l'âge je
remets pas en cause la parole des femmes
ce que je mets en cause c'est que nous
sommes dans une démocratie et que dans
le cas d'une démocratie il faut entendre
toutes les parties et d'ailleurs dans
dans le règlement de la Commission non
mais dans la règle dans la règlement de
la Commission LFI ils doivent entendre
tout le monde et ce qu'ils n'ont pas
fait et c'est ça que je reproche je dis
pas que Monsieur Bayou il est tout
blancs dans les écolos mais ça je trouve
que c'est absolument condamnable à
l'Assemblée nationale ne doit pas mettre
une gifle une claque doit prendre de la
hauteur
de la hauteur peut-être que c'est cette
femme on sait pas ce qui se passe
derrière les portes peut-être c'est elle
qui était en tort mais doit prendre de
la hauteur dialoguer avec elle et c'est
le message qui doit renvoyer à nous
Français et au monde entier
en matière financière pourquoi pourquoi
pas en matière de conduite vis-à-vis des
femmes enfin ça me paraît pas
j'étais élu par le peuple et il a sa
place à l'Assemblée aussi
je trouve que pour le moment c'est
normal parce que ça il y a les débats
qu'on a et ça démontre que pour le
moment mieux qu'il soit touché autre
sujet c'est c'est l'enquête du cevipov
sur les mers qui est assez inquiétant
d'ailleurs va d'abord une inquiétude de
grandissante des mers sur sur des
questions budgétaires et financières
parce que ils savent pas comment faire
avec les dépenses de la montée des
dépenses d'énergie pour chauffer les
piscines les écoles
mais dans cette dans cette étude il y a
notre notre sondage qui dit que 63% des
mères
ont été victimes d'agression c'est
énorme
vous voyez vous vous sentez ça
alors oui heureusement notre mère notre
ex-maire monsieur Carl le livre il a été
plusieurs fois menacé qui est député
maintenant il a été plusieurs fois
menacé courrier dans sa boîte aux
lettres
également une fois devant la mairie
quelqu'un qui a essayé de l'assassiner
et c'est une personne qui est très
proche de ses administrés et qui a évité
ça de peu donc oui alors qu'il va être
maire c'est on va dire c'est comme une
vocation donnée de soi donner de sa vie
familiale de son temps c'est pas un
métier qu'on apprend et avoir ça en
retour de l'agressivité c'est fort
dommage c'est rare de trouver des gens
qui veulent être mère il y en a plein
qui ont la
capacités
parce que je sais pas le panneau de
basket tombe
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est un
sacerdoce quoi
c'est une phrase qu'il avait prononcé
avant qu'il y ait autant de violence
contre les mêmes ils voulaient dire
voilà vous comprenez se faire engueuler
quand on était merde ce qui est plutôt
simple alors pour le coup mais que ça
aide jusqu'au violence c'est quand même
c'est vrai qu'il y a aussi une façon
générale enfin une une
moindre respect de l'autorité d'une
façon on le voyait tout à l'heure quand
on parlait de ce qui s'est passé à
Coignières mais c'est vrai il y a ça
aussi enfin après notre avocate l'a dit
tout à l'heure il y a les réseaux
sociaux maintenant tout le monde se
lâchait des bandes qui se forment en
réseaux sociaux tout le monde est
derrière à son écran
que faut-il faire faut lire juste ce qui
est positif et pas lire le reste mais
ouais les réseaux sociaux c'est en
graine mais je vais tout à fait d'accord
avec vous parce que je suis
adhérente d'un groupe de sur un réseau
social de de ma commune et donc je lis
un peu de voir ce que les administrés
écrivent il y a des moments je suis
assez je suis hyper choquée de la
violence qui peut être écrit contre une
décision une décision d'un maire ou
c'est quand même assez alors je pense
pas que ces gens là vont aller insulter
le maire vous j'en sais rien mais déjà
ne serait-ce que sur le réseau social
on peut se lâcher on peut tout dire en
plus c'est la fonction politique
préférée des Français le maire était
au-dessus bien entendu des autres 74%
des Français qui font confiance en leur
mère et il y en a 63% qui ont une bonne
image du maire et des honnêtes enfin etc
il est quand on dit la proximité avec le
maire je pense aussi que le maire fait
peut-être
un pare-feu c'est il est agressé par
procuration parce que à partir du moment
où la crise s'installe où il y a des
revendications on ne peut pas atteindre
l'état central on va voir le maire il
est tellement proche et il a vocation
elle est dans la rue il est plus facile
à atteindre donc il est certainement
aussi un moyen de de faire un relais et
ça c'est particulièrement ça
particulièrement sensible aujourd'hui il
y a quand même un grand paradoxe entre
le fait de voir cette violence monter
les cartes des mers alors que le maire
est quand même la personne est même en
termes de notoriété les trois ou quatre
cinq fois plus être plus plus connu une
meilleure notoriété que le député et
même que le sénateur je crois que le
sénateur est en étant en fin de liste
donc là il y a vraiment
quand on demande la notoriété il
connaissent ni la fonction ni le nom
c'est sympa alors que le maire c'est
vraiment celui des énigmes qu'on connaît
qu'on connaît quand on dit agression il
faut c'est à dire que vous voyez il y a
un tableau très complet il y a des
incivilités il y a il y a pas que des
agressions physiques heureusement dans
les dans les 60% mais il y a ce
sentiment très partagé chez les maires
vous avez vous avez fait le Black Friday
ou pas
donc vous êtes pauvres moi je suis pour
qu'est-ce qui est contre
[Musique]
je suis assez contre tout ce qui est on
achète un pull à 4 euros tout ce qui est
pris bas parce que derrière un prix bas
il y a un coût social que je trouve
grave et inquiétant et c'est vrai qu'il
y a des tas de jeunes qui vont acheter
des des habits notamment sur les habits
à des coûts extrêmement bas et voilà
derrière il y a des enfants qui
travaillent ça vient pas d'Europe ça
vient pas de France
faut pas prendre l'avion etc on fait
venir des marchandises qui sont faites
ailleurs il y a un coût écologique et un
coup de transport il y a un coût social
tout encore plus qui sont achetés
voilà je suis une association qui
récupère des habits de gens qui donnent
des habits et qui voilà faut pas qu'il
les jette il est donc que ce soit soit
recyclés soit vendu l'euro symbolique à
des personnes qui n'ont pas de revenus
et dans ces dans ses habits il croit ils
savent pas quoi en faire dans ces
associations il y a des habits neufs qui
n'ont jamais été mis parce qu'il y en a
trop donc Black Friday c'est beaucoup
alors après c'est vrai acheter machine à
café une machine à laver etc ça sur les
biens de consommation qui sont demandés
pour des gens consommer moins d'un côté
exactement vous avez des
contes économiste
le Black Friday aux États-Unis sur une
journée c'est 9 milliards de dollars sur
une journée 4 milliards et demi il y a
deux ans en ligne uniquement ça fait 6
millions à la minute de dépenser 6
millions etc
voir le effectivement vous pouvez avoir
le Bayonne line pick-up in store donc là
on achète en ligne on va chercher
une collecte mais alors il y a le Black
Friday il y a le Cyber Monday et puis
par contre aujourd'hui aujourd'hui mardi
le mardi suivant le cybermandais il y a
le giving
c'est apparu en 2012 en même temps que
le Black Friday qu'on a importé en
France en 2012 et qui consiste la
journée du don donc c'est peut-être une
façon de se racheter le fait de dire le
mardi c'est la journée du don alors ça
peut très bien vendredi
tu donnes à l'association voilà mais
c'est une façon de voilà de se démarquer
mais c'est la société qui est ainsi le
problème c'est que je suis endetté
d'accord avec vous il y a une forme de
il y a des biais cognitifs il y a un
billet d'ancrage un billet de cadrage
parce que quand vous voyez un produit
avec un prix barré a forcément vous
regardez même pas si vous avez besoin du
produit vous regardez l'affaire que vous
allez faire donc j'ai acheté parce que
c'était pas cher après
j'ai acheté vendredi on a parlé des
États-Unis on a parlé de avant les gens
roulaient sous les habits donc moi je
parle de aujourd'hui en tant que
consommatrice aujourd'hui avec notre
pouvoir d'achat qui a bien diminué j'ai
acheté vraiment des besoins primaires
des choses que je regardais auparavant
et les images je pourraient pas
l'acheter tout de suite je vais attendre
et ben j'ai acheté tout à moins 40% ma
crème que j'ai mis ce matin pour
l'émission que j'ai acheté vendredi
dernier qui était pour moi inabordable
et là moi 40%, c'est quelque chose
finalement
les gens quand ils vont en grande
surface faire leurs achats les cadis
sont moins remplis il y a plus personne
dans les grandes surfaces auparavant
vous aviez des queues surtout à la
rentrée qui allait jusqu'à la fin du
magasin on voit plus ça aujourd'hui donc
vraiment on est dans le besoin primaire
les vêtements et ben tout le monde
revend en revanche sur des plateformes
je sais pas si on peut dire le nom des
sur vinted ou de moi je suis une fan je
lui pratique énormément j'ai acheté
également de seconde main
ça fonctionne et moi vous et puis même
le troc je procède énormément au troc
quand vous voyez bon ben vous donner à
quelqu'un je troque en même temps ça
fait de la cohésion sociale ça permet de
rencontrer des personnes même des poètes
qui disent madame je vous rencontre
aujourd'hui bah vous êtes poète ok moi
je veux rien en échange moi vous
m'écrivez un petit poème et puis voilà
non mais ça je suis d'accord ça c'est
bien mais c'est une blague
63% des gens qui disent attendent le
Black Friday et il y a dans 63 63% et
dans cette partie on a un tiers qui vont
faire des cadeaux de Noël à l'occasion
du bras alors là j'ai un problème
dans un sens après tout le cadeau est-ce
que c'est l'objet que l'on offre ou
est-ce que c'est le sacrifice monétaire
que l'on fait pour acquérir un objet que
l'on va offrir donc je pense que là
aussi il y a peut-être une question de
de génération parce que faire un cadeau
et savoir qu'on l'a acheté
40 % moins cher est-ce que c'est encore
un cadeau ça ça peut être
mais en fait c'est si on pouvait ne pas
appeler ça le Black Friday
vendredi noir c'est pas terrible dans
notre
historique bon c'est pas terrible qui se
souvient qui qui sait ce que c'est que
voilà on est on est peut-être à
connaître mais sinon non mais arrêtons
de parler anglais j'en ai marre quoi
ce gouvernement qui passe son temps à
sortir des choses en anglais directement
enfin je veux le gouvernement qui sort
le bras de fer non non non
mais quand on a parlé du du Pass
sanitaire pa2s c'est bien le
gouvernement qui a sorti ça pa2s dans
quel esprit pervers est-ce qu'on peut
modifier du tout la langue
je sais même pas le Navigo
j'ai une liste j'aurais dû la porter je
vais apporter à la prochaine fois de
tous les choses édictées et dessinées
par le gouvernement qui sont directement
en anglais ou dans un franglais
lamentable etc c'est c'est même pas si
un ministre de la Francophonie en tout
cas s'il y en a il est discret il y en a
un pas de quoi mais un ministre de la
Francophonie
[Rires]
désolé pour elle de ses accusations
parce que c'est c'est exactement le
débat aujourd'hui entre il faut
consommer moins disent les uns et on a
le pouvoir d'achat baisse donc on se
précipite sur quand on peut construire
et la consommation est importante pour
une certaine classe de la société
contrairement à ce que ce que moi
peut-être
ce vendredi noir
on peut arrêter oui mais c'est mieux
sauf que c'est mieux que les soldes ce
sont des produits de mauvaise qualité
qu'on présente des produits qu'on voyait
jamais alors que Black Friday c'était
produit qui sont là pour une durée
limitée
[Musique]
pour les soldes
ça ne marche pas très bien dans les
magasins depuis quelques années
parce que important l'inscription de de
l'IVG peut-être l'inscription divisé
dans la Constitution
[Musique]
alors le nouvel article 66 de la
Constitution devrait être rédigé ainsi
la loi garantie l'effectivité et les
galaxies aux droits de la nature de
grossesse
c'était qui a été voté par l'Assemblée
notamment par l'accord de renaissance de
la nupes
c'est important ça change les choses que
ce soit inscrit
dans la Constitution
en demandant l'abrogation d'un article
de la Constitution après c'est compliqué
c'est à dire que là en l'inscrivant dans
la Constitution c'est sacralisé
c'est compliqué de l'inscrire dans la
Constitution parce que le le
process juridique c'est il faut que les
deux assemblées semblaient nationales
Sénat vote le texte dans les mêmes dans
la même écriture et puis ensuite il faut
que soyez un référendum soit c'est la
réunion du Congrès le président choisit
bon le référendum ça m'étonnerait c'est
un peu compliqué et long à mettre en
place au niveau de l'hôtel du territoire
donc ça c'est compliqué et ensuite ça
passe au Congrès et ce sera la 3ème de
voix pour pouvoir voter pour ou contre
maintenant je suis pas sûr que enfin je
suis assez même persuadé que le Sénat va
voter contre
déjà pour tes contre a déjà voté contre
je pense qu'il va revoiler contre mais
c'est dommage parce que ça sacraliserait
le principe alors c'est vrai qu'on est
c'est venu sur la table parce que c'est
une décision d'un pays étranger qui n'a
pas le même droit parce que c'est un
droit jurisprudentiel il y a c'est un
État fédéral enfin on est dans des
conditions américaines qui a permis à
chaque état de faire ce qu'il veut en
fait
totalement absurde parce que deux états
mitoyens il y a pas de frontières il
suffit de passer dans l'autre État pour
pouvoir enfin bon c'est en fait l'idée
c'est de justement qu'on ne puisse plus
jamais revenir dessus et on peut plus
abroger cette loi qui peut être un
risque je vous propose de d'écouter
notre invention de
bout de l'intervention d'Aurore berger à
l'Assemblée nationale sur ce sujet
ma mère a eu recours à l'avortement à un
moment où c'était illégal dans notre
pays elle y a eu recours comme peut-être
un certain nombre de nos maires de nos
grand-mères elle y a eu recours dans un
moment où elle risquait la prison et
elle risquait sa vie où elle a d'abord
fait appel à un médecin
vraisemblablement à ses connu à l'époque
pour cela mais l'opération ne s'est pas
très bien passée et comme pour de trop
nombreuses femmes elle a dû ensuite
aller à l'hôpital à l'hôpital où elle
pensait trouver un refuge un refuge
bienveillant un refuge accueillant elle
a été reçue sous une forme d'inquisition
parce qu'on avait bien compris
évidemment l'acte qu'elle avait tenté de
réaliser à ce moment là
et alors
qu'elle était dans les mains de médecins
et bien ce qui s'est passé à ce moment
là c'est qu'elle a en effet pu mettre un
terme à sa grossesse mais qu'elle a subi
un curetage sans anesthésie voilà ce qui
se passait voilà ce que les femmes
subissaient voilà ce que nos mères ont
pu subir
évidemment
on se dit qu'on n'a pas envie de revenir
en arrière quand même il y aurait que
des femmes qui ont de l'argent qui
pourrait aller dans des pays étrangers
pour le faire et du coup les femmes qui
n'ont pas d'argent elles se feront
avorter dans des conditions dramatiques
est-ce que quiconque en France il y a le
moindre risque qu'on vienne en arrière
non on n'est pas aux États-Unis comme le
dit très justement Florence Merkel des
États-Unis c'est un État fédéral c'est
autre chose je me fous de ce qui se
passe aux États-Unis
qui recommande la suppression du droit
d'avortement pas un seul donc voilà il y
a pas le moindre risque aujourd'hui il y
a pas de risque mais on sait pas dans 10
ans
il y a peut-être plus important en ce
moment que que de s'occuper de
l'installation de la Constitution je
suis très attachée de rendre
l'avortement mais il ne me paraît pas du
tout remis en cause alors voilà
finalement s'aperçoit que on reconnaît
des droits inaliénables à l'enfant ou à
la mer et quand à partir de quand
peut-on parler de l'enfant du fœtus etc
dès le moment de la création certains
disent dès qu'il y a conception mais on
peut reconnaître finalement des droits à
ce qui est conçu d'autres considèrent
que si c'est conçu en dehors du mariage
en dehors du contrat c'est moins grave
donc c'est un crime moins grave c'est
des auteurs qui qui nous disent
finalement c'est un crime auteur c'est
c'est quand je crois un manuel Kant qui
disait hors du contrat de mariage le
crime est mineur si on considère ça donc
et puis et puis elle est libertariens et
là qui sont un peu dans l'idée de de la
tolérance qui nous disent mais
finalement et il y a un auteur qui
malheureusement décédé qui était un
collègue Bertrand leménissieux qu'ils
ont peut faire un marché libre de
l'adoption qui serait la solution à cet
avortement parce que pour lui
l'avortement c'était finalement la loi
du premier occupant c'est-à-dire il y a
le ventre et l'enfant le ventre la femme
donc c'est le premier occupant et
l'enfant c'est un peu comme un comme une
clause comme une expropriation donc si
on ferait venir le juge uniquement aussi
le propriétaire et le locataire avec
quelque chose à se reprocher le juge et
sinon il y a le marché libre de de la
notion de l'adoption et puis on a une
solution voilà et finalement on arrive
que finalement Bertrand le ménissieux
avait finalement réfléchi la chose de
façon originale
là tout ce qui a été expliqué c'est
assez juridique c'est assez ambigu donc
il vaut mieux sécuriser donner le droit
et qui peut le faire
comme vous dites il y a pas forcément de
risque immédiat mais risque c'est
justement on le voit que quand il arrive
de toute façon ça va pas être inscrit à
la constitution alors dernier dernier
sujet on va parler on va parler un peu
de la de ce que nous dit au fond le
débat sur la corrida qui n'a pas eu lieu
à l'Assemblée
[Musique]
alors justement tiens je vais vous
donner à priori comme ça pour à 10 je
vous demande mais je connais des
réponses vous êtes vous êtes en charge
du bien-être animal donc en plus c'est
marrant monsieur a mis une cravate rouge
est-ce que c'est fait exprès
[Rires]
vous savez que vous savez que les
taureaux ne voient pas la couleur
d'accord donc les gens qui disent en ami
du rouge pour les exciter non
c'est pareil pour eux
bon je suppose que vous êtes contre
voilà vous c'est une très bonne
supposition et moi je donne
l'affirmation ouais ouais je suis contre
moi je n'ai pas assisté en vrai à une
corrida j'ai assisté à des rodéo mais ça
n'a rien à voir mais il y a des grosses
bêtes aussi donc n'oubliez pas donc mais
la puissance du taureau me semble
tellement tellement forte que je ne sais
pas si j'arriverai à supporter le
spectacle de la mise à mort en fait
c'est ça par contre je reconnais je
reconnais les raisons et d'héritage
culturelles qui est derrière
je comprends pas pourquoi on pourrait
pas faire une corrida sans mise à
morts
avoir aucun respect du tout mais
Jean-Charles moi je serai a priori
légèrement compte mais je suis
totalement pour que ça continue à
exister alors est-ce que est-ce qu'on
peut être contre et est-ce qu'on peut se
dire oui mais il y a des traditions dans
le sud de la France et après tout les
traditions c'est peut-être quelque chose
qui est important qui est une sorte de
résistance à la modernité
non vous comprenez ça c'est bien
[Musique]
il s'agit pas d'arriver dans un dans une
arène et puis de buter un taureau si
vous avez déjà mis les pieds ne
serait-ce que dans une étable face à un
taureau un peu un peu vif de 500 kg déjà
totalement à l'aise donc c'est pas aussi
facile que ça d'une part et ensuite il y
a une chose intéressante de parler de
bien-être animal alors certes la fin
d'un taureau de combat est un peu
sordide mais sa vie est un bonheur
absolu c'était c'est-à-dire c'est pas
comme les vaches dans des élevages
horribles que qu'on peut avoir en France
et en Europe qui voit même pas une
touffe d'herbe de leur vie eux ils sont
pendant quatre ans dans une liberté dans
une Camargue magnifique et voilà donc
certes la fin et moyenne
de la priorité de la cruauté je dis pas
le nom de l'émission
c'est que les animaux qu'on mangeait
mieux qu'ils ont été abattus le taureau
a été combattu ouais c'est quand même
c'est différent
de toute façon il va mourir quand il
rentre dans la reine quoi qu'il arrive
sauf si il est gratuit
si lui blesse ou qu'il le tue il y en a
un autre qui arrive pour
toute manière il est condamné c'est ça
qui est normal
de foot
avec ses enfants en sachant qu'il y en a
un des deux qui va mourir à l'intérieur
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette idée là
avec ses enfants
il y a des programmes de télévision qui
sont bien plus effrayants pour les
enfants qu'une corrida c'est moi mais
justement parce que on va pas sur le
fond après tout même l'Assemblée
nationale a refusé de battre mais il y
avait un article très intéressant dans
le Figaro dans le philosophe qui
s'appelle Jean-Claude Michela qui
explique ce que nous dit au fond la
corrida de du mouvement LFI c'est-à-dire
que au fond il y a il y a dedans il y a
une tendance marxiste un peu qui est
représentée par des gens comme ruffins
et puis une tendance beaucoup plus
sociétale
qui représenté par Caron enfin par ces
gens-là et et et et c'est possible que
le taureau est plus foncé sur RFI que
les filles sur le Tour
des dynamiteurs de la société ils ont
pas ils ont pas pour objectif de la
changer mais juste de la dynamité je
pense mais pour en revenir à la corrida
il y a dans ce cet article du Figaro ce
philosophe ce qui était tout à fait
intéressant c'est que il disait chez les
gens qui sont pour la Corrida il y a
toujours on comprend toujours qu'on
puisse être contre la corrida oui en
revanche sont contre la corrida ils
veulent même pas en débattre il en est
contre puis les gens fa sont des
assassins des cons etc il y a pas de
débat possible et c'est ça ça me choque
un peu moi par exemple je suis
absolument contre la peine de mort je
peux accepter l'idée que quelqu'un ne
soit pas totalement mon avis je vais pas
pour autant avoir envie de désintégrer
voilà je trouve que ça manque un peu de
de discernement de la part des
anticoridas
c'est qu'il y a enfin je pense un
changement de nos pensées de comp
vis-à-vis des animaux il y a déjà dans
la loi ça a évolué et c'est vrai que je
pense que je pense que c'est un
spectacle qui est condamné à sa qui
condamnait à mort à terme de toute façon
la corrida c'est vrai que on supporte
plus du tout ce qu'on supportait avant
la façon dont traiter les animaux en
gros c'est ça
des jeux de tout ce qui voit qui est
très agressif là d'aller à un spectacle
moi je suis tout à fait pour le débat je
représente aucun parti politique comme
dit je suis le bras droit de ma main
droite j'interviens par rapport à mes
convictions par rapport non non
on va dire ça
mais bien sûr en fait tout ce qu'on on
le dit même les trucs ce qu'on mange
c'est influence notre corps il y a des
comportementalistes qui interviennent
même également dans dans les écoles pour
apprendre aux enfants à comment bien
traiter son chat
le comportement oui des humains envers
les animaux on change beaucoup beaucoup
matériel donc là il y a une prise en
compte quand même de de cette affaire
la corrida du patrimoine immatériel donc
là
aucune liste des endroits où la corrida
est horizon en France parce que
finalement on dit c'est dans le sud de
la France mais là encore c'est la cour
d'appel de Toulouse en 2020 qui a dit
PACA Occitanie une nouvelle Aquitaine
rien d'autre et puis je termine avec ça
c'est que les taureaux font partie de de
l'élevage on voit pas distinguer taureau
d'élevage pour la Corrida autoroute tout
court et la commission
comment le Conseil européen il n'y a au
Conseil européen que la France l'Espagne
au Portugal on sait pourquoi qui
s'oppose à ce que des subventions soient
versées c'est quand même de 100 millions
d'euros par an qui sont versés aux
éleveurs de taureau pour la Corrida on
va pas faire la distinction les taureaux
de combat c'est une race
alors que alors qu'on fait quand même
dans le droit la distinction entre les
animaux domestiques avec les bien se
comporter et les animaux sauvages sur
lesquels il y a pas de bagues merci
parce qu'on est déjà dépassé le temps
c'était passionnants merci merci à tous
les quatre et très très vite pour un
nouveau numéro de PAF
[Musique]